[Musique]
une dizaine d'individus ont détruit des
caméras de vidéosurveillance à oyonnax
dans l'ain des mains ou même était
découpé vous voyez à la disqueuse ces
caméras avaient été installées dans un
quartier de trafic de drogue moi ce qui
me fait peur c'est la délinquance et
l'absence de réponse pénale en face de
cette délinquance bah c'est simplement
mon
souci c'est la peur aussi
d'une intrusion d'une autre culture j'ai
des biens d'une autre région et d'une
suprématie d'une autre culture le comité
miss france à attaqué aux prud'hommes
par l'association osez le féminisme en
cause les critères de recrutement jugé
discriminatoire les candidates devant
mesurer au moins 1 mètre 70 être
célibataire et sans enfant un concours
qui violerait le droit du travail selon
l'association ce qu'on a reproché aussi
chez hanouna c'est d'avoir mis comme
boucliers ma chère et tendre épouse qui
est sénégalaise bon c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas une parade c'est simplement de
dire écoutez moi je suis de droite mais
je suis le contraire d'un raciste mais
le contraire l'exact contraire donc on
peut être de droite et pas dire les
étrangers de huf pas d'enfant il ya une
raison c'est que elles vont énormément
bougé l'année de leur élection
sincèrement alors c'est vrai que je
trouve ça dommage moi je suis une femme
d'entreprise j'ai deux enfants je les ai
levé en plus seul et donc en
l'occurrence je me suis organisé donc ça
je trouve ça obsolète cette volonté
d'avoir des miss disponibles
sexuellement puisqu'on doit être
célibataire sans enfants peuvent pas
marié véritable comment des célibataires
on est disponible sexuellement c'est
l'idée à travers
les mythes du patriarcat cette idée de
contrôle des corps des femmes c'est
christian jacob lui-même qu'il
appellerait sur les réseaux sociaux elle
est belle mais on y voit les six
candidats tout sourire autour de la
table de café viennoiseries le mode
horde algérie sarrazin
on souhaite ainsi une des nerfs de soi
semblement c'est ce qui compte unité il
rassemblement une véritable équipe avec
l'ambition travaillent ensemble la
volonté commune de porter cet esprit
d'unité de rassemblement
3/10 servi votre débat ça a servi à
donner du courage à prendre la lumière
pour rappeler que vous êtes candidat à
vous existez oui voilà sans doute c'est
ça parce que vous savez monsieur bourdin
je suis pas voyez vous moi je ne cherche
qu'à prendre la lumière vous non et moi
je suis que ville un couple
d'enseignants de l'académie d'aix
marseille menacé de mort par courrier
depuis la rentrée une des lettres reçues
chez eux contenaient une photo de samuel
pâtit avec le ministre de l'intérieur
nous avons d'emblée réagi et évidemment
de la façon la plus le plus ferme qui
soit de façon d'une part à protéger et
d'autre part à poursuivre car comme on
dit au fait que avec monsieur zemmour on
n'a jamais vu ça racisme pareil étaler
son rapport aux femmes est absolument
stupéfiant il pense qu'elles ont un
cerveau diminue et il veut enlever la
parité deux pays veut enlever le droit à
l'avortement c'est un homme qui déteste
les femmes c'est pas nouveau c'est
quelqu'un qui depuis longtemps déjà sur
ses propos en résumé ça une des tests
non je pense qu'il ya un peu plus de
réflexion je pense que c'est un homme
qui déteste les femmes il a une vision
de la femme qui est une vision
qui réduit et capacités des femmes qui
réduit leur espérance qui réduit leur
pouvoir puisqu'il dit lui même que les
femmes ne sont pas faites pour
accéder à déposer vos chats que sa
propre sur les femmes
oui ça me choque
[Musique]
vendredi dernier un semi remorque chargé
de voiture est restée bloquée à un
passage à niveau à dakar ville dans
l'oklahoma un train alors percuté
violemment le poids lourd
[Musique]